[Music]
hello how's your health chrome day with
your briefing today is wednesday
may 26 las vegas police are
looking for a driver who hit
a woman and fled the scene near
washington and peaks this  it happened last
night authorities said a woman
was in the assigned crosswalk
when she was struck the victim was
taken to hospital with serious injuries
anyone with information about
this incident is asked to
contact police immediately
changing the subject today is the  last day
for cis justin students this
school year began with
distance learning due to the pandemic in
march schools modified their policy
by running a hybrid model with a
large group of students attending
classrooms two days a week on  Next
school year is scheduled to start
on August 9 completely in person
however if it is day 1 it will offer the
virtual learning option.  al for a
certain number of students
the clark county school district
on the other hand announced an
adjustment to the rules regarding the use of
masks inside the campuses
students and employees who are
fully vaccinated will not be required to wear
a mask masks are
optional for kindergarten
through third grade students but
fourth and fifth grade students must wear a
mask and those who are vaccinated from
sixth to eighth will have the option to
choose between wearing one or not
[Music]
now we go to the weather forecast
we start  with the sky partly
covered in clouds but then we will have
mostly sunny skies during the
course of the day winds from the south west
temperatures in the hot 90s
to end the month of May
expect 100 degrees to start June
next week have a nice day
greets you  Héctor Mejía and this was his brief
information about them in Spanish
[Music]